hello everyone on the internet watching
this video how are you I'm fine thanks
for asking how are you dead yeah great
what we've got for you today oh so just
above that oh yeah
so why are we doing it today on this
village from Acer well what happened is
I know this happens quite a lot
I discovered video games come out right
and obviously from my hood it you'll
know that our master video in fact I am
an achievement hunter in my spare time I
play games - you plays games doesn't get
paid for it slightly different so EA is
brought here to blow stuff up basically
yeah we're an old military base and
we're gonna reenact some stuff from
battlefield 4 let's run the clip oh yeah
grenade yes so you might be thinking oh
well I wouldn't trust this lemma guys
with the grenades but they somehow gave
me this who trusts me I said it don't
give me thank you I shouldn't be behind
I'm scared more like that so basically
what we're gonna do even though there
goes perhaps we're gonna blow up a load
of stuff you know just throw a grenade
on the floor and then we're gonna blow
up something with it yeah if you're okay
with that we'll commence
alright so we're at the wind you are
obviously a specialist and explosives in
the British Army what do you know about
frag grenades okay demo aichi frag
grenade here okay it's got two two
safeties here got the safety pin first
thing you do is you pull the safety pin
out then you've got a fly off living
here that's spring-loaded and you hold
that in with your hand like so okay so
the first thing you can do pull the
safety pin out then this is
spring-loaded like I mentioned before
you're gonna throw the grenade that then
asserts itself and that would spring
round there's a striker which comes
around with the falafels Eva okay and
that impacts on the fuse the fuse itself
at the label position within it okay and
that lasts between three and a half and
four and a half seconds burns down into
the main film of the grenade which is
155 grams of RDX and TNT in a ratio of
about 54 to 46 percent right so delay
composition burns down initiates the
main fill which detonates at about 6,000
meters a second right then on the inside
you've got a steel coil wrapped around
the inside around the pot of the the
outside of the grenade right that's got
notches in it and that provides the pre
formed fragmentation for the grenade
itself so let's write initiate and then
that's what kills people is this the
second time you've been smart in a slow
mode recipe yes yeah you're really - in
like five minutes really rattling so
we're gonna have the grenade there and
Dan and I will be safe behind this
little blast shield and we're filming
with a fan to flex
[Music]
[Music]
very fast isn't it yeah yeah they look
at those pretty cool what do I want to
do next I reckon we should do an
apartment in cuddle yes your anklet
we've got plenty of puddles yeah maybe
that one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well we took care that pesky puddle but
one thing we haven't shown is that you
know the destructible environments and
stuff battlefield and all that we should
blow something up that is destructible
whoa wait wait I'm gonna stop you there
again that is a shame because exactly
well how about instead of that then yes
scout the area and we'll see if we can
find just a random lead to being stacked
a bunch of explosive barrels video game
style more the chance isn't that
probably really high we're talking about
yeah probably what's gonna happen guys
look yeah wonderful fun exactly what we
wanted
[Music]
ready
[Music]
that was absolutely massive wait wait
stay away from the camera what it's
completely why out damages I was running
away jumping away how how was it died
yeah it's good
I sprained another thing is it was
natural cuz I was like holy crap oh my
god let the concrete thing got blown the
door seems to make it in tact that oh
yeah careful look at mental again again
sauce
[Music]